tame
はいっ
ん
ええええええ
いやー靴はですねー
台風はなくしまして
いいいい
終わったいや終わっております完全に知事の
からの批判がよるで結構なベルまだ探したんだけどまだなくて
まだ100
帰ってこないよ
人がを聞いていて
全部聞きましたはい
レッドの人も僅かに探しますちょっともう一度ちゃんとさせてみます
それかなぁはい
今で待たせしておりますありがとうございます
とりまたら5頭の子住所教えていただけますか a はいありがとうございます
イベントに入り説明いたします
泣きそうこんにちははじめた超です単刀直入に言いましょう
車検76万円の財布をドビ
その中に入っていたすべてのクレジットカード免許証と保険証キャッシュカード
救出してしまいました
なんで
なーん3日4日くらいずっと今東京にいるんですけどちょっとすごいバタバタしてて
いろんな場所に行ったり個別の撮影とはしたりパタパタしててその多分移動の中で
亡くしたんだろうなと思う
いやホントにね怖い全く切りないしちょっと今回ばかりは値段が値段なんで176万円
の際工夫して済ませてやばいんだ
本当にまずいよね動画にしてるのもちょっとどうなのかと思うがヤバイんですよ
ちょっと急行を辿ってみましょう
[音楽]
何も出て来ません財布なくす気づく直前もタクシーでずっと動画の編集してておりた後
も動画の編集してたんでもう何だろうファイフに対する意識がゼロだったんですよね
ウイングの人と一緒に乗ったんで私の支払いも産むのか立ってたんでもう財布の存在
すら頭から抜けてたけどえぽん上の記憶が正しければ最後に財布を見たの
がトミック札自慢したところなんですよと戦と別のスタジオで撮影してとミクさんに
これ176万円で財布なんですよちって自慢するためにわざわざカバンから出してそこ
から飯食えず名
とミクさんが犯人財布がない
まずれないですねっ
やばいですよねヤバイというか間違えて盗んだりしてないですか
じゃって最後に見た場所からなくなって気付くまでの場所で僕が辿った道はたったの3
つしかないんです1つはその撮影していたばその会社そこから支えられたのタクシーで
帰ってきてからの部屋このさん宅に絞られてるんで多分あが財布を落としたらすぐ
気づくと思うんですけど
を落とすてはないと思いますと僕最善無くさないように加担高いれるんでかバンドだ
からっ
ないよもう死ぬほど探してはたいという現状です津波に部屋の中もベッドの下もその
会社にも電話したしタクシー会社にも出ましたしできるところは一応全て探したんです
けどもなくなって1日が経っておりますねちょっとさせが276万はやばいの多数がに
ヤバイ
ちょっと心がずっとざわついてるんですよホント
代が高すぎるんですよというわけでまずは警察にでキュッというわけでまずは警察に
いってこと
っていうわけでまずは警察に行ってこようと思います
[音楽]
大神田家がなんかもう1回ちゃんと探しました服もリュックも袋とは全部確かめたし
ゴミ箱も見たけど全部なかったです終わりました人生だけど僕は一切身分を証明できる
ものもないし最後はないしお金も無いフレーズ伴い保険もない不審者です私も電車にも
乗れないんでちょいもの人に1000円あります僕は星の朝まで生き延びなければいけ
ないして税
1回警察署に行ってまずで紛失届を出していこうと思いますでは
えっ
ああああああ
[音楽]
エルメスの脅威財布です
いいにするんじゃないかなじゃあ3002
あえて受けて交番に行ってきましたじゃあまだ届いてなくて紛失届受理番号っていうの
貰っては見つかってないんですけども3つ鍵次第
僕の携帯に連絡がくるという形ですけど
ただ見つからないあんなでかい財布を追ってたらすぐ見つかるはずなんでただも警察の
ところには届かないと思うんですよね
とりあえず回家に帰ります
アイテムで帰ってきました鼻水が止まらなくなってしまいました
マッサーないです落とした僕が悪いんでマーサーないんですけどもなくしがすごい人が
176万円の財布を持ったところで
ちゃんとダックスということがわかりましたありがとうございましたちゃんと検証結果
が出たので良かったですね
なく知って気付いたことがいろいろあったんですけども珍しく胃が痛くなりました
なんかずっと先からハチに襲われてて凄いですやっぱり107
図6枚を失ったっていうのはなかなかこう身体に異常をきたすことが今回分かりました
やもうね3つ感ないよーここまで来ると多分
伊予いいよただただ自分を悔やむばかりで
ヤバ珍しく言葉が出るなぁ
ちょっいやーちょっと諦めないで頑張ってみます
とりあえず今日はふて寝しますおやすみなさい
俺はいいはいああ私は第8お客様のお名前漆塚8村小田色文字のような形の
あえだと申します
サマデイ
すぐさま芸がはいはいこれははいっ
ano hi me
レター
皆様でございまーかっ敗8分けています
ありましたヤッター
[音楽]
ヤンホンでられ me
new 連絡という
まっすーっとてもないですよねマット作りましたん
ee
ano hi ni
nyanonon
んだ東西骨 labo 生です以前に
以下はわずか入ってますんではいえーと
a
いただければいい
我シャフトへ行きませんまっ
はい rename
はい目にくい理由うございます
いつであったあああ
財布を取りに行きます a 3
puni
ほんとれるだろうさ
[音楽]
本当に俺はさん
梓はい
グランデねパワー救うんです北へ2分だ
じゃあ3000ですああああ難題だったん